do you ever wonder how your rates are
spent great spiria across the district
depending on services offered in your
area however on average each day a
resident will pay seven dollars thirty
three and rates so where does that money
go
one dollar forty a day is spent on out
roads in footpaths
thirty one cents are spent on waste
collection and disposal forty six cents
goes towards the running of our
districts libraries and 27 cents helps
build and maintain our community
buildings fifteen cents a day is used
for health and safety things like animal
control building consents and cemeteries
seventy-three cents is required for
planning governance and administration
costs things like civil defense district
development and council meetings
26 cents is for other miscellaneous
costs such as promoting our districts
economic development and contributing
towards the canterbury museum 39 cents
is assigned to our swimming pools and
aquatic facilities while 17 cents
assists with our ongoing earthquake
recovery one dollar fifty nine cents
looks after our waterways stormwater
drains and provides safe clean drinking
water it costs another $1 to deal with
sewage leaving eighty cents a day to
maintain our parks reserves in sports
grounds so thank you for playing your
part and building and maintaining the
wonderful Womack Aditi district
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]